一時代が youtube を築き上げた伝説のアイテムご存知たのかアルミホイール
2まあアルミ箔をまとめてなんかこう
館鎮魂と[ __ ]じゃねカチコチカッチコチと販 bank アルミハト
固めてヤスリで磨いたりするとすごくきれいなルーミーなぁアルミホイルを固めてきて
美しい玉が出てるんだが想像
主上最大9歳プンっ
[音楽]
アブで作られるずっと超巨大なアルミホイールがまあ大丈夫みんなでめちゃくちゃ時間
かけて来た時まくって最良な音200でぎゅーっと作ったアルミホルダーなんですけど
もういいてくださいこれ
このサイズでこの光沢はもうギーザーちょっと汚いですけどここらへんは上の方とか
見るとかなり一例なんですねこれ
相当な人数と相当な時間をかけて作ったこの超巨でアルミホイール玉
大事な綺麗なんだろう俺と愛にほいれただから居る第二匹ばその音声になるかなナブ
ことですね
12キロです止められ212キロ分使ってんだなこれ
そんな中目が見る機会はないほどの大きさのアルミホイールだが何回か私僕たちに
アルミホイ
玉の断面を見たいなちっちゃいあるデフレがはの断面とかあの youtube で
やってる方がいらっしゃったと思うんですけど僕3時ませエージェンシー小さい小さい
です僕はもっと大きな大きなあるのフォルダーの断面図をファーってみたいんで今回
この超巨大な10キロ越えのアルミホイールための断面図を見てみたいと思いますデー
子
4日
[音楽]
ていた
はい
4つ埋めてみましょう
ていました
じゃあいいそう
a ですで話だ俺だね主体よ
うーん
ます
ガーッ
voodoo
準備完了しましたあるいは本音が着るときなチェーンソー男のほうがいいかなと思った
んですけども小さ適用キューブものなんですよホームセンターの人に聞いたらこっちの
がキー的な金ができるんだったらこっちのがいいですよと言われたんですけども初めて
です
[音楽]
はぁ
1本
rejet
[音楽]
ああああああ
は
木こういうアイテム好き皆さんやっていきたいとおもいます
よろしくね所
10個
一番ついておうわぁ
[音楽]
[笑い]
car
時間が取れな絶対時間5分なパターン
安全ですを認めることはたぶんないですね
がんばれああああああ
ウェーバーチョンだから行けそうではあるんですけどとうとう事件通りそうな気持ちが
わかります
気合い
いいした
皆さんが想像してる以上にかなりヤバイアルミハーブのそう和服次だこれやばいなぁ
頑張ります本当に誇り切断するじゃん
15分がやってみたんですけど今こんな感じ切れてはいるんですけども相当は時間と
いいですねこれ
黄金なモンスターはリーダーなんですけどもうちょっと頑張りますが
疲れたてきたと思うんすけどね人前の半分もいってないんだろうなぁ
やばいよこれ
3種
[音楽]
えっわー
英ザパパっってなんかパパってなっちゃったんですけど
パター
a そっかーではなんかそうになってるからな
こういうなんか卵の殻みたいな現象でおけるんだろう
半面だけだけなっちゃったよこれ半分目カーブを抜けちゃったってことは
まっすぐこっちもじゃああーやっぱりかーやっぱりか
こっちもやっぱりできるか立ったすっげーこの両方の皮だけ受けました
[音楽]
あ駅まあはい今にまあ
year
いやー
[拍手]
ああああああ
皆さん朗報です金属用のブレードを手に入れました
今まで何してたんでしょうここからも完全に金属用のビデオに帰るんでもっと早く進む
気がします
ああああああ
安全な方わかった
[音楽]
tar
ちょっと待ってちょっと待っていっ
うーんまたまた
で割って1打でどんどん小さくなっちゃですねマッド漁師から何かこれは問題文やって
もさ
結構取ればいい
悪役やカバとれるは逆恐れるはそれはねなんかマトリョーシカみたいになってきて
どんどん小さくなっちゃうんですけどやっぱり団名ができると盛って取れるんだなこれ
このサイズだからこその現象出っ歯を選ばれどんどん増えていっちゃうでしかも今
止めて言っください本当にあった
本当に本当でもないからここに1校ですうんちょっと本当になれる本だよ
飛んでジャンプします
ざっとわかるほっ
同じ言葉しか出ないって
[音楽]
はい実は1時間ほどやりましたねチェックを
闇不快感時に起きましたねかめた的にはほぼ切り10 z もこれ結構深くなってる
けど
ことがまだやっぱ浅いかななんかまだもうちょっとあるんでもうちょっと切ればいけ
そうな気がします
2時間くらいやってみましたみてください結構毛仏壇ても中が
もあるよねこれあるあー7
こんな撮影したことないですねそう
現場からは何も伝えられませんただ限りなくもバカバカに近い上半身音が真ん中にあっ
とちょっとだけシーンが残ってるみたいな状態でスポーツ頑張ります
tar
絶対も使い人の動きしてるこれもなんかもうさんなんか泣けたら割れそうな日が[ __ ]だな
ちょいって投げてみますかそれぞれたら一番よねいきます
ホッ
[音楽]
あ
a
ああああああ
[音楽]
あの地球の断面図だだけど地球の断面図の何取るとかのやつみたいになっちゃいました
綺麗に割れてよそこは書庫きれいにはるってよ
それも泣かん
こっち側したパパって何なかったので彦ばできるとすれば残念なんでちょっといきます
はい
んはーはっはっはもどって来るイカ丼又吉火山これも中身こんな感じになってますね
ココアの部分がねまだな金ってうちれなくてちょっともうちょっと書きそうです
うっ
持っていた
[音楽]
シャアこれをここにお家は完成しました
丹前なる断面図で超巨大なアルミホイルでも完璧に綺麗に切り落としたらこんな感じに
なりました
もうすぐ何層に分かれてますねアルミホイールがなんかもうほんと馳走みたいになって
ても恐怖だな感じぐらいなんですけども
german ない方ドーンといえば選手ゴリゴリに固めてやつ買ったんで
でも取れるしたねそれが多分これなんですよめっちゃ硬いやつが1個入ってて
マッサージを取り巻くように南宋のあるみたくがこんな感じに入っていたっていうのが
超
巨大あるいはフィルタもの中身でございましたはいこんな感じでしたね
いやーすごいよ
俺の一日を返してくれ
bl gl パッケージ